-How are things going?
-Things are good.
Things feel --
There's a lightness to the
country right now, right?
Yeah.
-Very effervescent.
-Yeah! There's this feel--
I think people feel heard.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like the nation
just feels like --
everything feels good.
In fact, around the world.
I think every country around
the world is feeling good.
Feels a little bit like
every country in the world
is in their own bathroom
with a shotgun in their mouth.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, I was
with my friend Dennis Rodman
recently in North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
And we were -- I was just
doing some advance work.
-Sure, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But I was thinking about it,
like, really the moment that,
like, whatever
you say about Trump,
I do weirdly think there's
something about North Korea
that he did --
that fire and fury thing,
I feel like Kim Jong-un
was like, "Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, you psycho like me, okay."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, you want to jerk off in a
Maserati and drive off a cliff?
Okay."
[ Laughter ]
It feels like -- I think about
like the Obama presidency,
and it feels like a dream.
Like, it feels like
a long time ago.
Like, it's like, when I think
about the Obama presidency,
it feels like -- it's like
a rainy Sunday afternoon.
You're at home,
you don't have anything to do.
You're like, "I'm gonna
turn on Netflix."
And you're like,
"I've never seen
'The Great British Bake Off.'"
[ Laughter ]
"They're so nice to each other."
-Yeah.
-"This is so pleasant."
You kind of fall asleep.
You wake up.
You got a [bleep] on.
You're like, "This is --
I think I'm gonna have sex
with a Swiss roll."
And you're like,
"This is terrific."
But that is the thing with Obama
that people won't admit
is that, like, he kind of --
he kind of put me to sleep.
-Right.
-Like, there was --
And I can tell by the audience
laughter and applause to that
that they agree.
But he really -- like,
there was something about him
that, like --
like, you'd start a debate.
You'd be like, "All right,
Barack, what do we got?"
And then he'd be like,
"Well..." and then...
[ Laughter ]
...you'd kind of be like...
"I know I agree with him.
Gonna pass out
for a little while."
I don't think I'll think
of the Trump presidency
in the same way.
-Yeah.
-Like a nice, rainy
Sunday afternoon.
I think the Trump presidency
will be like
it's 3:00 in the morning
and a fire alarm goes off,
and it just starts
raining in your room.
And you go outside,
and it's daylight.
And there's, like,
a bunch of lifeguards, like,
beating up a gerbil.
And you're like,
"What's happening?"
[ Laughter ]
I think that's how I'll remember
this presidency.
-Yeah, that's a pretty good way
to remember it.
Well, I will say that
a nice escape
from everything going on
in this world is this film.
This is a very funny film,
"Uncle Drew."
It's also a very sweet film.
-Yes.
-It's a nice film
about a family.
-Yes. Yeah.
-You play, by far,
the worst person in the movie.
-Thank you.
Yes, I do.
-But the other people --
You know, this is Kyrie Irving.
This is Nate Robinson,
Reggie Miller, Shaq,
Chris Webber, Lisa Leslie.
I mean, they're all --
these are basketball players
who are very, very funny.
-Legends.
-Yeah.
-And they are -- they are --
It is crazy, 'cause I decided,
I was like,
"Yeah, I'd love to do
this movie.
It'll be fun.
I'll be funny.
Maybe I'll play
some basketball with them."
It turns out that
they are so much funnier
than I am good at basketball.
-Right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Which was a huge bummer.